I felt that for 20 years I had to
dedicate myself exclusively to
technology.  I almost had to convince myself
that those passions didn't exist.
Almost all the founders I
worked with at YC always said to me, "
Dalton, when are you going to start
your own company again?"
Perhaps my greatest regret is that one day I'll
look back and think, "Wow, I didn't
get to explore all these things."
I think I've always lived by the
philosophy that if I put in a lot of effort
and tried to do a good job with
interesting people, yes, interesting things would happen
.
Very good.  This is Dalton and Michael, and today
we're going to talk about
life changes.  I don't know about you, Dalton.  I've had a
couple of life changes.  And you? And you
?
Yes, there are many new things.  A
different environment.  Changes for the
spectators.
Yes. Yes, we have a microphone in our
face, which is uncomfortable.
There are some differences.  There are some
differences.
Yes. Yes. Well, what do you do now?
Well, now I'm an emeritus partner at YC and I
've created a new venture capital firm
called Standard Capital.  A
big change.
Yes, it's a big change.  A
big, big change.  For me, who
am also an emeritus member, I still
have many office hours,
which is crazy.  But it's been
incredible.  I've been encouraged to try to
help improve San Francisco and it's
been quite an adventure.    It
sounds very easy.  Fix, fix
San Francisco, Michael.
Well, as a technician, let me tell you
that
you have all the answers, right?
It's that easy.  You're the one.  It has
been a lesson in humility, to put it
mildly.  It has been great
fun meeting
public officials and learning something completely
new.  I think at the beginning of the
conversation they are a little surprised
when I don't start with
technical answers.  I say that I don't come with my
own recipe to say, "Why are
n't you bad at what you do?"  Have you
thought about using AI? Have you
thought about doing these things? Have you
thought about the
public safety issue? Have you thought about
appointing all adult men as deputies
and recruiting them for a
police force? Who?
And that's been really fun because I think
people are a little taken aback when I
say I don't know anything.  I like the
government.  I believe in government, but I do
n't really know anything, and, you know,
maybe between 1 and 6% of the things I
've learned in software and
technology might be relevant.  And
the rest is something new.
That's very humble of you.
You're probably thinking, "Do they think you
're deceiving them?"
No, I think what I learned is that
tech bros arrive with a bang and
fast.  Quite aggressive.  Okay.  So I
think that in 5 minutes they think
this is a different conversation.  And it
's funny, because many times I
end up asking if I can see what's going on
.
Mhm.
In other words, can I look around? Can I look
over someone's shoulder? Do
they have control panels?
In other words, can I see someone
doing something?
Yes.
And I'm starting to wonder if I would do it or
could do it differently.  And
well, it seems that this has been a
very different approach.
Anyway, to move forward,
why did you decide this was the
right time to do something new?
Yes, I mean, look, for me,
I started with 25 lots, and that's a nice
round number.
Yes. I
also have a newborn; my
daughter was born very recently, at the end of
February.  And well, you know, we've been through
this, man.  You go through many
vital reflections about that.  Yeah
.
Besides, honestly, dude, you're leaving, I can't
say that hasn't affected
my overall psychology.  That's definitely
something I'm thinking about more.
Yes. And look, I'm really excited about what I'm
going to do next.  I
love my job.  I love working
with founders and I love doing
office hours.  You know, in fact, I
love the job.
Yes.
And I'm excited to be a
founder again.  I've always found it a
bit strange to think, "The founders are
great" and all that.  And you think, "
Well, I'm not a founder. You know,
I was an employee here."  So you
see, it's really liberating to be able to
start a new business from scratch.
As we have talked about it a lot on
our YouTube channel.
Yes.
I literally signed all the
documents and set up the payroll and it was
great.  You
know, I did all the things we
've been talking about.  And I'm very
proud of it.  It's great to start
something new.    That
makes sense.  So, in terms
of helping everyone else here,
I think it would be interesting to talk
generally about how people should make
big decisions in
life.  Yes. It
was funny because I think there were a
couple of people I talked to
about this who put me in the
right frame of mind.  The first was my
former co-founder Justin.  And you know, I
was talking to him.  I told him, "Yes, it's
been 11 years at YC and all that
. And you know, maybe I could do
this job until I retire."  And
I could hear it like naked judgment.
What did it
sound like? What did the naked judgment sound like
?    I just
felt like, you know,
you know someone for a long time
and he said something that really resonated with me.  He said, "
You could literally write out everything
that will happen between now and
retirement if you stay at YC. And it's
like, is that the life you want? Do
you want a life that's so predictable
? Especially since you have
financial security."  And I said to him, "
Yeah, I mean, you love
chaos, Michael."  Let's be honest.  I
love it, I like chaos.  You
love chaos.  You love it.
Yes. Well, he knew how to get under your
skin.  He knew
how to drive me crazy.  The second
person is my wife, Sarah.  I was
talking to Sarah informally
about what life is like after
retirement.  I love chaos and
planning, which is something you already
know.  Anyway, and he told me something that really
moved me.  He told me, "You've spent
your entire adult life in San Francisco."
I told him, "Yes, I moved here when I was
23."  And she told me, "You know, you spent 10
years giving back to YC because YC
changed the trajectory of your life."  And
I said to him, "Yes."  And then he looked at me.    He
said to me, "So, are you going to do something for
San Francisco?"  And I said to him, "
Well, she knows how to get under your
skin. These people in your life know
where to push you, man.
And it's weird because I've always thought
to myself, you know, it's easy
when you're in tech. It's like,
yeah, I guess I live here. But my
users are all over the world,
right? You know, like you could
say to yourself, oh, aren't you
post-local? But when you wake up and
think, this is where you've spent
your entire adult life. You know, you're so... maybe there's
an obligation there." And the
last one was Steve Huffman from Reddit,
who said casually, sometime
last year, and it always stuck with me
. "I hope most
of the capable people we know
end up doing some kind of
public service before they
fully retire." And he said it so
inevitably. I mean, it's as
inevitable as you having a
will or having,
like, you know, how
could you see yourself without...?
That's no more far-fetched than him
being the CEO of a  Public company.
You know what I mean? In the realm
of plausible things.
Yes, exactly.
That's definitely possible.
And it was funny because those things were swirling around in my
head. And I think what I
've noticed about making big
decisions in life is that people
tell you things all the time, but
when it becomes clear, there's something
deeper happening when you can
quote them live a couple of weeks, a
couple of months later.
Yes. And
you? Were there any conversations that
helped shape your thinking?
Yes, I mean, I have to admit
that almost every founder I
worked with at YC was always saying to me, "
Dalton, when are you going to start
your own company again?"  "I'm sure
you've done it too. This is one
of the top five questions I
received as a partner at YC. They were always along the
lines of, 'Hey man, just between you and me,
when are you going to start your
own company again?'"  And I would say, "No
, no, no, this is great." I always
had my answer, but the first thing
that comes to mind for us
YC partners is that we're all
founders. And it's hard to corral
founders in one place for
an extended period of time.
It's tricky. It helps when they have
kids or other distractions in
life.
Yes. I think that definitely stuck with me
. It's just the fact of
constantly getting asked about it; I've
had several answers that, to be
honest, were true. And then, look,
talking to my wife and family about
having total autonomy over my schedule,
autonomy over what I spend my
time on, autonomy over all those
things, is pretty important.
Yes.
And if you think about the advice we've been
giving people on
YouTube all these years, we always
tell them to go the
high-agency route, to go their
own way.
Yes.
Even though it's difficult, you'll like
yourself more doing what's
comfortable, you know? So  Which I think so
, talking to my wife about a lot of
these things in terms of, you know,
our schedule and our
family life, made a lot of sense. And look,
I'm super excited about how well
AI is working for our
portfolio companies.
Yes.
And if you think about it, this is my equivalent
of starting my own startup using AI.
Right.
I have the founder and market fit
to be an investor. It would be very difficult
for me to start a purely
AI company.
Well, you have to be careful with that
term founder because, you know,
people on Twitter shout "venture capitalists
" when... It's
true. Well, I think it's when they're not
the founders of their
venture capital firm and just say they're
traders.
Well, for what it's worth, I think it's
true.
Paul Graham is really the founder of
YC. That makes sense. Like, Paul
Graham was a founder when he started YC. An
investor, right?
Exactly.
Yes.
I think it's completely fair, but
the founders of
venture capital firms, I think they deserve the
title.
Fair.
I think, you know, Ben and Mark from
Andreessen, those are the founders of
Andreessen.
Well, there aren't that many. I've been surprised by how
few people seem to start funds
to build institutions.
Yes. It's difficult.
Difficult. I agree.
And that weighed on me quite a bit, because there's
this great innovator's dilemma
where, if you try to graft
artificial intelligence onto an
existing business, it's much
harder than starting something from scratch.
Yes, generally, in the YC portfolio,
we like to fund disruptors from scratch
for existing industries
that use AI to run
their businesses rather than trying to
buy a company and then implement
AI in it.
This came up very aggressively in
the mobile world, where
you and I both know many
people who worked on
mobile startups before the iPhone. And you'd think they
were in the best position, you
know, it's like, oh, they're all set
. As in the mobile sector, it happens with
the iPhone. None of the
YC winners had that profile. Like the
YC winners in mobile, they started
after the mobile launch. That's why
I think there's something about it, if
a  New technology means you have to start
from scratch. Otherwise, you wonder
if you're really going to embrace the new
technology or if it's always going to be
the classic innovator's dilemma.
You have to do it, and we see that in
our current SaaS portfolio. I see a
lot of people with massive
SaaS revenue streams who know AI is going to
revolutionize them, but does that mean they have to
give up all that
revenue?
Yes. You've
done all this before.
It's tough. I've done a lot of
this stuff. You know, it's hard to
let go of what's worked and
gotten you here.
Yeah.
Instead of doing something new. And well,
that weighed heavily on me, and honestly,
talking to founders has also been
inspiring because they're like, you know,
find your own way of doing it,
but keep working, man. Keep
doing your crazy investment moves, and
I think that's been great, like all the
notes I've received. I know you
received them too, announcing that I was going to
do this and leave YC. The
huge amount of good vibes.
Yeah, that was crazy cool.
I think, as a note  Besides, one
perhaps strangely unfortunate part of
doing YC for so long is that you
touch so many people's lives. But
for you, that's just part of the day-to-day.
Yeah.
And seeing all the responses we
both got when we announced we were
leaving, I thought, "Oh, [ __ ]."  It was
like a big reminder, like, 'Oh
my God.  As if you were the
main character' "."
Yes.
In the lives of thousands of people.
Yes, it was great.  It's like the story of
Mark Twain, what was his own
funeral like?
Yes. Yes. Yes.
Yes.
And I like to listen to what
people have to say.
Yes.
It's great.  And you'd never get that
amount of
good vibes under any other
circumstances, except when...
Yes.
There's a big life change.  So it's
a way of taking stock of
where you are in life.
It's a feedback loop that you can
only access if you take a big
leap.
Yes.
No, I totally agree.  I think
the other thing for me, and I think
every person is different.  I remember
having many passions besides
technology.  And I remember that when I
was trying to make this decision
, I felt that for 20 years I had to
be focused on technology
.  I almost had to convince myself that those
passions didn't exist.  Because that's how it is, it's
a difficult game, and when you
're not focused, it's an
impossible game.  But one of the strange things,
one of the strange techniques that
helped me, uh, got me expelled from
university.  And in order to motivate myself and
graduate again from Yale, I thought I had to
make a life plan.  I think what I was
really responding to was
that those institutions at that time,
like Yale, didn't motivate me.  I thought
I would be as motivated to graduate from
Yale as I was to get into it
.  And it wasn't like that at all.  So it's
like, okay, I have to put
other things out there where graduating
is going to be a prerequisite, but this
isn't the ultimate goal.  So for
me it was a simple plan.  It was money at
20, family at 30, government at
40, retirement and teaching.  That was a
plan I made when I was 21.
When are you 21?
When he was 21, Dalton.  And it was
funny.  I told this to someone and they
said, "You're crazy."  He told me, "It's
crazy to even think about planning
your whole life."  And I think people who
know me very well tell me, "That's
pretty much in line with my style."  "But
for this person I was
talking to,
Michael, it's crazy to plan your whole
life out. No, I'm not with you on this,
man. No, I'm not with you. It's not for
everyone, right?
Yeah. Not for... Your experience may
vary, but it's been 20 years. And
things have awkwardly followed that plan.
And, well, you know, I just turned 42,
and I think subconsciously, in
the back of my head, it was like, the plan.
Like, what's up with the plan? The plan
has been working. What's up with
the plan? And I would have been more than
happy to change the plan if I'd
felt it needed changing,
right? Like, yeah, yeah, who
cares, right? It's not like everything
was perfectly planned. And by the
way, that's not such a detailed plan
, is it? I mean, it's like one
word per decade. But, it kind of
reminded me of the other things
that I really liked. You know,
going back to what Justin said, like,
now I have the opportunity or the
privilege of being able to explore these
other things that I like."
Yes.
And maybe my biggest regret is if one day
I look back and think, oh, I didn't get to
explore all those things. And for me,
that really fit because it was like,
uh, well, like, this is just the
next phase of the plan. Right? This
is just the next one. And what's
really funny is that going into
each of those phases, I didn't have, you
know, you start a company with your
co-founder who wears a camera on their
head streaming 24/7.
You're not...you're not charting a
direct line to money.
Right, right.
You're not charting a direct line
to money, are you?
And, you know, family was kind of like
, you know, I was 30, I was
dating my wife, but
we weren't married, we didn't have kids,
right? Like, da da da da. Um, and so
for me it was like, this plan
never works, where you take a
leap and it's like a sure thing.
Yeah.
This plan always works, where
you have to take a leap and then you have to
feel your way down. And  That's what's
been so fun for
the last 3 or 4 months, like taking that
leap and then realizing, "Oh
[ __ ], I really like these other
things."  I still love
technology, but does it have to be 97
%?  No, I don't know.
There are enough people who can
take the lead in the
technological aspect.
Yes.
And that has been incredible.
I think I've always lived by the
philosophy that if I put in a lot of effort
and try to do really
good work with interesting people, then
yes,
interesting things will happen.
And that's how I went from being just some guy
in Texas to
this crazy life journey I've been on
.    It
sounds like a good life plan.  I
understand,
but have you seen what I'm saying?  I
thought...
Or philosophy of life.
Yes, it's totally a philosophy of life,
which is that I should always be
uncomfortable.  As if I were always
right at the limits of my
abilities.  I should always
push myself to the limit.
Yes.
And, again, we've done some
crazy things together.  You understand what I'm talking about
.
Yes. How to reinvent YC will run
on Zoom.  Yes. COVID was fun.    It
was right at the limit of our
abilities.  While we had children.    You
know, back when we had kids.    I have
always been my own worst critic
and, to tell the truth, I have always been very
hard on myself at all times.  And I just
wanted to feel like I was giving it my all
.  And if I kept
doing this, it would only get worse over
time, making my life really
interesting.  And yes, I have somehow
subscribed to that theory and I still do
.  I think that, for you
, perhaps a question I could ask you
is what was something contradictory
that people don't know that the founders do
n't know about the creation of a fund
.  Something strange, something different.  Not as a
strategy, but rather something internal
.  At the end of the day, many people in
large companies or successful franchises
,
Mhm.
They know in their hearts, if they are self-
aware,
Mhm.
that people are kind to them
and respect them because they work in an
important and powerful place.  And you know,
there are two ways to deal with that.  One
of the two is that you think you're
special and you say, "Oh, I'm a PM on
Facebook. I'm very important. I'm very
important."  In other words, I only send
private messages on Facebook.  They are
some of the best people in the
world.
But basically, I'm
very good friends with a Facebook PM.  You
are.  Basically, you're confusing the power
of the place you work in with
yourself.
Yes.
And then, you
untangle yourself.
Yes.
Your identity and your professional identity are
the same thing.
Yes.
And you just get confused about what's
what.  People who are not
self-aware are simply
unaware of this and, you know,
they leave an important job and are left
in shock.  And then I think that self-aware people
are
aware of this.
Yes.
And that's why they stay in those jobs
forever, because they think, "Hey, if
I leave, no one will
ever be nice to me again. I'll lose all the energy I
had."  That's why they stay.
And I think that's what keeps
people there.  They won't admit it
publicly, but I think many
stay in their jobs
with the self-awareness that the
moment they leave, no one will ever
return their calls.
People might think, "Wow, these guys
have it all under control. These guys
have it all under control.
Yeah.
Every day must be
stress-free."  No, this is
difficult.
Yes.
Um, just like I imagine trying to
fix the city government is
difficult.  This is the hardest thing I've
ever done, man.  I've done many
difficult things, but starting something
from scratch, especially on the scale
of what we're trying to do,
yes.
This is objectively the hardest thing I've
ever done.
If you have that mindset, and I
agree with you that, if you only know
how good you are when you're at that
moment of maximum tension, at that
moment of maximum stress, it's almost
like another reason to consider making
a big change in your life, because it's as if you
only know your maximum
speed and your maximum capacity at
those moments.  Correct.  And the same thing
happens when people don't have to
tell you yes.  TRUE?  They're
giving you a real grade.  Not like...not like
again.  You
know, it's like the people in the government.
All these people are retiring from their
government jobs and...
Yeah. You
know, imagine being treated
differently when you retire from a
government job.  Yes.
I would say that, in my case, I don't want to
take on the responsibility of fixing
the government.  It's a
task that will take at least 3 months.
I think the only thing that excites me is
trying to help.  But I think what I
can do that might be interesting
is to review a little bit of what I've learned.
Yes.
And this is like a summary after, I do
n't know, 90 to 120 hours of
conversations with people from the
city government, conversations with
citizens, and reflection.  So
I would say it's the first input of
knowledge.  The first thing, I think what
is most obvious to me and what
scares me may not be obvious to
other people, is that most
people who work in
government try to do the right thing.
Most of those who work in
government are capable people who
actively choose to earn less in order to
give back to society.  So that's
something very important.  So the
second thing I've learned, and it has
surprised me a lot, is that I was expecting
more smoke-filled rooms.
I expected people to want this,
but for us to do this other thing
.
That's what people also think
about technology.  Yes.
Yes.
Or do they actually think there is
much more coordination?
Yes. There isn't as much coordination as
people think.
There are many problems that, when I
got to the root of them, turned out to be
our politicians doing and our
government doing the things we said we
wanted.  And then it turns out we didn't
know it
was a bad idea.
Something like that.  It reminds me a lot of when
you listen to your users and they
tell you that
something is going very wrong.
Yes, I want all the text
on the website to be black, and the background
too.
Yes.
And it's difficult.  You can't do
A/B testing in the same way.  It's a
difficult environment, but I was surprised by how
often they said, "Yes,
we did what the voters told us to
do."  And I was thinking, "Oh,
[ __ ]. Okay."  I mean, the other
thing I didn't realize is that,
in the same vein, we, as
citizens, drive the bureaucracy.
I think this story is not being told
the right way.  It's always portrayed
as if we were victims of
government bureaucracy.  It's as if
we're pressuring the government
to create rules that make it less
efficient.
Hm.    It's
as if there's a rotten apple every time
.
Yes that's fine.  We say, "Let's make
all new rules. How could
this have happened?"  And then there are 50
new rules.  And if a company were managed
this way, it would never work.
Large companies are managed this
way: when something bad happens,
they establish all the rules; the
scar tissue is created to prevent
something bad from happening again.
But large companies cannot
do it as well as the government.  The
government can create rules that
can land you in jail if you break them.
No, that's the crazy thing,
the police enforce them.
Yes.
So I think it's a fair rule.
Very good, perfect point, perfect point.
But it's like, but once again, we
triggered it.  It's triggered by
someone who made a mistake, whether
honest or not, and we think:
how could you let that happen?
How is it possible that the government didn't
play it safe for 100 years
with everything going right?  And that's very
important, and I wonder if you think you're a
victim of bureaucracy, like
a municipal worker is the biggest
victim of bureaucracy.
I think the other one, which is of that type, and
this applies outside of government, but
this really affected me.  We've
talked about this before.  As if it were taken
for granted that
software companies create their own tools
.  It's like a muscle they have, and that we've
always had.  And I think what I'm realizing
is
how many organizations don't have that
muscle.  Basically, if we're
using software, it means that some
vendor is developing it for
us.  It's sad because think of
how many small tools we created
at YC.  We thought: God forbid,
most people already know Bookface
, right?  God forbid, we'd have to
find a supplier that sells
YC alumni merchandise.
We are like a request flow provider
.
Yes, exactly.
As if we
wanted to change some text in the
application and had to call
someone, call our
account manager.
Yes. It would
never have worked.  And I think I
just took for granted how
often we were making our
own tools.  And now I see
organizations that struggle to
create their own tools.  And
that's bad.  And I understand why,
right?  But it's more difficult.  I think
the other thing that keeps coming up is
that you think the government has these
powers and these responsibilities, and you don't
want it to be a human operation,
you want it to be a machine.  It's like,
well, the permitting process is bad.
This supervisor can draft
legislation to improve it.  These
people have to vote for him, that's it
.  And when you start talking to
people, it's like everything is obviously
human.  Everything is human.  That's why it
's really nice to be the kind of
Twitter techie and try to solve
all the city's problems with a
tweet, you know?  And the more I
learn, the more I feel that, well, the
other day I had this thought which was
basically the following: Like, you
know, it's easier to try to advise
a founder on how to build a
successful company.  It's easier,
you know?  With the amount of
research I've done, it's not like there are
no conclusions.  There isn't...
Oh, that's great.  I thought you were going to... I've been
waiting for the conclusion
my whole life.
conclusion.
I thought you were going to fix everything.
solution.  This is difficult.
And, by the way, it's
different for me.  Normally, with
this level of commitment to
someone's company, they would be able to
offer advice.  I'm nowhere near
what...
So, iPads aren't the
solution?    I'm
afraid.  It's like everyone
needs an iPad.  No. To
regain it, I have even more respect for
people in public service.  It's
as if they were taking on the
most difficult problems.  Yes. They don't
pay them outrageous amounts of
money.  We're making their lives
harder as citizens, and then
we screw them over.  And then they're
subject to the wind like any other
business, but we pretend we're in
this hermetically sealed,
government-controlled environment.  I used to
think startups were one of the
most stressful and difficult jobs
imaginable, and I thought, "
Yeah, that sounds tough."
This is like "yes".  It's as if sometimes,
in my conversations, I feel I
have an obligation to express
compassion.  I think, "I respect you for
doing this."  So, in short, I think that's what
has made me feel
humbled and amused, and it's like
where I live.  So, if I want to
contribute to the place where I live, I have to
learn these things.  Most
people can have a
renter's mindset, but others must adopt a
homeowner's mindset at some
point.  And I feel like maybe I've been
renting...
Yeah. For
too long, you know?  So that
's
very noble of you.  I think a lot of
people are lifelong tenants,
man.  I'll make
some t-shirts.  Finally, one
last piece of advice for people watching this
video who are considering making a
big life decision.  Maybe it's
starting a business, maybe starting a
family, maybe moving to the
Bay Area.  What do you think?
You know, this is the trick I
recommend.  I think people are
used to writing guidelines
for LLMs.  And you realize after
writing prompts for a while
that the better the prompt, the more
likely you are to get a
response.  You're still with me, right?
As if you had to dedicate time.
And I believe there is a superpower that we
can all develop.
Okay.
To develop the guidelines for
ourselves and think of them in
that way when we make decisions.
Yes.
It's like, you know, given these
limitations or given this and given that
, and you try to formulate your thoughts
in a very coherent, linear way.
Yes.
And then I think you tend to get
pretty good answers.  And the
instruction I keep giving myself is, if I
were doing office hours
with myself,
Mhm.  What would I say?  Because by doing that
, a
completely different part of my brain is somehow activated.
Because we're, you know, we're so
used to giving advice about
things.  I always say, "So, what
advice would I give myself?" And I've
had a lot of it. You know, I'm not
sure that works for everyone,
but I've been very lucky with those
kinds of prompts. And generally, I
think thinking of your own
thoughts as prompts and
trying to pick them out is a
pretty good trick, man.
I like that. I think if I try to
extract the prompt, maybe it's
subconsciously giving me, it would
probably be a version of, "You've been
incredibly lucky."
When all is said and done, what
story can you tell about how
you've given back, like, in gratitude
for being so lucky? I don't think
you can deserve to be lucky, but I do think
if you're lucky, you can
thank the world. And how do you maximize
that? I think it's interesting, and I think
YC gave me a great opportunity for that
, but I think maybe government is
one of the only places that gives you
more opportunities to do that. Okay
. Well, great talk. Welcome back
. There will be more of these. Have
a good day. Thank you. We should
do them.